eight suspects are now in custody in
connection to the vicious murder of a
New York City teenager hundreds of
people filled the streets yesterday in
the Bronx to remember 15 year old
lisandro Guzman filiz a relative says
the gang suspected of killing him
admitted on social media that they had
attacked the wrong person DeMarco Morgan
is in the Bronx close to the scene of
this terrible vicious crime DeMarco good
morning to you good morning there is a
growing memorial just outside of the
store where Guzman Fillies was murdered
and the gang members believed to be
involved in his death reportedly thought
Guzman Philly's had leaked a sex tape of
one of the gang members relatives of the
family saying they don't want an apology
they want justice mourners filled the
streets frustrated with the violence
that cost an innocent teen his life I'm
so confused I can't I can't cope with
the fifteen-year-old to known as junior
was beaten stabbed repeatedly by five
men he was able to walk himself to a
nearby hospital after the attack where
he died dr. Phil eases juniors mother
his father rushed home from a job in
Florida when he learned about the attack
but it was too late
I'm mysha mysha community members
mobilized online under the new hashtag
justice for junior police used social
media to solicit tips and were flooded
with information which reportedly helped
identify multiple suspects all of
juniors suspected attackers are alleged
members of a gang known as the
trinitarios family members believe the
incident was a case of mistaken identity
and claim the gang even apologized to
them on social media
sorry no apologize I'm gonna bring my
son back
he was a good and fluid kid juniors
parentsí he dreamed of becoming a
detective New York Police Commissioner
James O'Neill was at his wake along with
hundreds of others I'm thank you very
thank you for the support for everybody
make me feel I sure my son gonna have
justice a GoFundMe page set up for the
goose pond families family has raised
more than two hundred forty thousand
dollars cardi B reportedly donated eight
thousand dollars to that fund
there is a memorial another week set up
for sometime tonight and his funeral is
scheduled for Wednesday since Lester
Marco one of the worst stories I've
heard you know the mom said that her
she's forever changed that her heart
will never be the same to hear that this
guy was a really good kid I know good
student and wanted to be a cop I wanted
to be a cop school officials said he was
a kind sweet always smiling
that makes some sense